okay so here's where I'd be you I always
like with panels right you always start
with something that you can establish
something that everyone can agree on and
then you are I think you say well where
can I take this logically right so
here's where I'm going to begin I'm
going to say this okay now this is and
this is one of the first surd laws that
you learn one of the very first ones
okay so in fact it's the way that you
simplify if I gave you something like
this sometimes you can simplify this
right what would you do to simplify that
well actually give me the steps though
just told me answer what would you how
would you write that okay so you
actually already go on a step further
you see that in there is the square of 5
which is 25 so you would you're thinking
this right but on the basis of that you
can break this third into two sons do
you see that right so that's why were
you about that is 25 root 2 which is
following yeah you're happy with that
so in fact we do this loads and so this
is kind of an established idea right
okay now's where it's going to get a bit
tricky right so I'm going to try
particular values of a and B I'm gonna
say that a and B both the negative one
okay now I could actually choose a
variety of different value C that would
still bring out this paradox but let's
just try it anyway okay so what I get on
left inside is this very naked 1 times
the square root of they did one so far
so good yeah what am I gonna get on the
right-hand side I'm gonna get it's fair
enough negative 1 times negative 1 yeah
okay now we define the whole idea of a
square root is it's whatever number like
the square root of a is the number that
if you multiply it by itself you get a
you're happy with that that's by
definition so therefore if you take the
square negative 1 times the square
negative on whatever it is what should
you get but on the right hand side
what's happening over here what's
underneath the spirit zone
which is just one right and the squirt
one is one sir what's going on okay now
remember all right if I say like the
square root 25 it's just five right like
as if that's that's the way we define
this oh and so this is this halts so far
so the question is what's break it down
like that's a suggestion but that has to
do well actually you're very close
obviously there's a side problem going
on but why is it that like usually we
would say square root 25 is just five
not plus or minus five okay so where is
the problem in here now the problem is
actually up here right it's right at the
beginning everything else like
numerically that I've done it's all fine
to understand why this is a paradox
we've got to understand why on earth we
say this in the first place like this is
not obvious okay like for instance it's
fairly easy to establish the square root
of a plus the square root of b is not
equal so this grid of a plus B right
this is a very common error that
students with their first letting out
thirds here like oh yeah root 3 plus
root 2
that's just root 5 right like it seems
like it works like arithmetic but it's
not so different so it's not at all
obvious that this is the case so I'm
gonna show you what's often always never
done which is I'm going to prove why why
that is the case okay so you can leave
in the middle space I'm going to leave
that there and on the side for you we're
gonna take this idea and we're going to
try to explain it okay so follow along
with me we're going to prove that like
where does this come from okay so I'm
gonna say let the left-hand side let's
just call that let's just call the next
given name okay and the right-hand side
that's also give it a name and this is
something that happens if that's all the
time
you've got to the--
X&Y they both depend on the same
printers so they should be related in
some way right the question is how are
they related so here's what I'm going to
do how do I get these two connected to
each other their square roots how do I
get rid of square roots I squared right
so let's try X let's square that thing
right now be careful don't assume
anything this is what X is by definition
so go to square now think back if you've
got like two numbers and you square them
okay they're by definition that's M
Squared it's grabbed right because this
is an intermediate line here stuck in
here this is n times so you can see
there's two M's to it you're happy with
that so therefore here this is a squared
times root B squared top of that so
there's maybe that's what I get when I
Square this guy okay what happens when I
square the other guy that's the square
root of a B well square which is also a
babe okay now I had my connections okay
so I've got x squared + y squared
they're equal to each other that's
really good
okay now clearly get my color back in
clearly X equal Y that's one of the
solutions to this equation
do you agree with that like X or Y the
same number that when you square each
one no big deal right in other words
this that's x equals this that's why
okay that's one of the solutions but can
you see it's not the only solution look
more carefully this right there's
another solution to this how can I make
it more obvious one of these you should
remember is when you try solving don't
divide through like I'm dividing this by
exits my YS that's a
IDs dangerous so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take this guy over here
subtract Y squared because now I can
what can I do to this left-hand side
yeah this is a difference of squares
right so I'm going to factorize like so
and now you can see now you can see
there is not one but two solutions for X
right there's Y which I already said but
there's negative one which I get from
here is that okay so what does that mean
okay
that means that this this is only half
of the truth right it is true X does
equal Y a lot of the time but only
equals y when you'd be a positive and be
a positive this is awkward
okay so really what we're supposed to
say is it's got a good at B's might be
better if they're negative then in fact
the square root of a times the square
root of B sometimes is equal to naught
squared maybe but negative the square
root of a B namely depending on these
guys here what a and B are right a and B
are negative if then equals something
completely different which is really
weird
most people just sort of take this for
granted but if you guys go forward and
you do accept you to max when you eat
off which I don't encourage or we see
how you guys but if you go ahead and you
do that like this idk and numbers which
are we call these imaginary numbers when
you combine them in other words with
complex numbers I'm just standing there
well and not just assuming the stuff
that you do from like the real world
those rules it's really important that
you push on what you see you